le cerf-volant c'est on pourrait presque
dire c'est une activité ludique de plein
air qui a toujours été celle des enfants
d'avant il ya bien longtemps même avant
nos grands parents et qui nous
permettait en tout cas d'aller prendre
du plaisir le week-end et pendant la
semaine c'était à l'époque le jeudi et
on se faisait plaisir et les concours
pouvoir celui qui aurait le plus beau
cerveau reims lesquels est le plus loin
le plus haut alors l'essentiel
là c'était un concours créative it est
en fait beaucoup de créativité concours
de précision parce que le compass est un
modèle de précision au millimètre près
de cerfs-volants n'oublie pas de la même
manière
et c'était aussi une inventivité au
niveau de la composition de
cerfs-volants sur le classement des
couleurs sur la toile là que c'était
tout un ensemble c'est presque une
oeuvre artistique au cerf-volant alors
quand on dit cerf-volant il ya beaucoup
de termes qui reviennent tech marotte
etc
comment peut-on expliquer ces thèmes
alors ces tissus des combats de
cerfs-volants qui se faisait avant entre
les jeunes
alors lorsqu'on voulait attaquer
l'adversaire ex au cerf-volant il
fallait manier le film et faire obéir
son cerf-volant afin qu'ils puissent
couper le fil de l'adversaire et gagner
le combat alors les expressions venait
du fait que chacun user d'astuces et
trouver des mots pour invectiver son
adversaire mais tout ça de manière
thématique un texte c'est quoi un texte
c'est quand on donne des à coup sûr le
fil du cerf-volant peux me permettre de
danser ou le fêter il n'a pas de
l'adversaire cerveau lamentable c'est
quand le cerf-volant à le fils coupés et
qu'il commence à se perdre dans les airs
et à tournoyer jusqu'à ce que des
enfants
agglutinés plus loin attendait
connaissait voulons tout pour les
récupérer
alors comment va se passer cet
cette grande fête intergénérationnelle
dimanche au vauclin alors il ya d'abord
une fois une marche et après cette
marche c'est bien nous avons fait des
ateliers de cerfs-volants pour les
enfants et les adultes
et puis il y aura lâché cerf-volant tous
ceux qui ont des cerfs-volants pourront
venir lâche et le cerf-volant est aussi
nous allons montrer aux enfants que le
cerveau dans cette activité saine du dic
et qui pourront eux-mêmes confectionner
leurs cerfs-volants et de faire monter
tout de suite sur le terrain sur le
front de mer à château paille